Andrew here's the pneumatic pulsate
Maryland this could be the answer to the
NHS's prayers a prototype ventilator so
simple that thousands of them could be
made within a fortnight shall I put the
compressed air in yes please yep fast
enough to meet the expected surge in
patients critically ill with coronavirus
you're ready to intubate
it's the first time it's been tested on
a medical dummy and it works the chest
rising and falling all controlled by a
jumble of wires and electronics for now
but sony has offered to turn them into a
mass-produced circuit board five
thousand of them a week this is
something this is something you could
knock together in a weekend's
mass-producing it will be dead simple we
can go from this little rat's nest to a
very clean PCB circuit board in the
space of a couple days a week ago
engineers and Ernie statists at Oxford
University started to brainstorm the
government's urgent call for more
ventilators their stripped-back design
lacks the bells and whistles of modern
machines compressed air squeezes a bag
in a box blowing oxygen into the lungs
reliably and safely we have gone back to
basics we've gone back to probably the
state of ventilators 10 or 15 years ago
which is no big problem we've also used
components that we already have on the
shelf we repurposed them
we can't break there's no motors to burn
out there are no moving parts to snap
and it can be assembled very easily by
anyone with the plans we're going to
make freely available to any fabricator
who we can get on board it's simple but
it will keep people alive
kovat 19 has overwhelmed well resourced
hospitals in northern Italy alarming
doctors in Britain the NHS has just over
8,000 ventilators the government says
30,000 will be needed innovation is
needed in ventilators and ventilator
production and so we're working very
hard to work with the business community
who are really putting their fingers out
on a whole variety of fronts to help
build new ventilators and make sure that
as many are available as possible but I
mean - you're honest there isn't a
country in the world that has the stops
of ventilators that needed when you have
a pandemic like this the oxford team
pitched their design to the Cabinet
Office on Monday - hospitals are on
standby to test it on coronavirus
patients it might be simple but in the
coming weeks it could be a lifesaver
Thomas More Sky News Oxford